[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in evan mcpherson the
bengals rookie kicker the 52-yard game
winner
feeling pretty confident there on the
sideline before that kick evan
i i would say i was um and i think
that's probably one of the most
important things as a kicker to have is
confidence um
so just to challenge myself with
something like that uh was it was big
for me and just to know you know going
out there that i had confidence in
myself my teammates had confidence in me
to uh to go out there and hit it all
right so how did you say it to burro
that uh i guess we're going to the afc
title game or the other guys on this
island how did you
how did it come out
well it kind of came about just because
i was i just taken my last kick into the
net and me and brandon allen were
standing by the heater and he was just
kind of telling me you know you got this
um you're going to make it all this
stuff and and so joe um you know runs to
the right falls down we take a timeout
and i'm kind of walking to the field and
i turn to brandon i'm like well looks
like we're going to the afc championship
game
i mean i didn't want to go into overtime
honestly i think our team deserves you
know to end it here to not play more
football kind of get rest and and kind
of get ready for the next game and so
that i could that's the least i could do
for
[Laughter]
you're such a nice guy you know the
generosity there that you want to make
sure your you know the starters don't
play any more than they need to let me
go out and end this thing do you watch
the kick go through
i i did not personally uh i watched it i
would say
probably halfway and then at the halfway
point i mean the way the ball was flying
in the way it felt off my foot i kind of
knew
that i was probably going through but
obviously
clark harrison kevin huber sapper and
holder they watched a little longer than
i did you know just to make sure it
didn't hit the
quick left turn at the end like it did
in green bay
what is the pre-snap routine for you
uh i mean pre-snap routine whenever i uh
when i jog out into the field is you
know we kind of get the spot on the
ground and
i kind of have a word with kevin i'm
like you know let's
it's one kick you know let's just put a
good hit on it and uh
just start on the right line it's going
to go through
and so you know me and kevin we probably
have like a little conversation there um
and take my steps back and probably two
deep breaths uh right before i kick the
ball and that's kind of
what i do any defenders yelling at you
at that moment
uh not that i could hear um i think
clark and the whole line could probably
tell you a lot more than i could
do you care if you're you know frozen
you know they freeze you as you get
ready to kick uh no not really i think
uh
sometimes i think it could be an
advantage because you know
kickers typically if we hear a whistle
we know we get a like a practice kick
and so it's kind of like a mulligan in
golf let's say you have your practice
kick you miss it
um you get to come back and you kind of
learn from that miss or you make it
you're going to do the same thing the
next kick and so i think it's honestly
it could help a kicker more than it
could hurt him what's the
distance that you would tell coach
i'm good from here like how how how far
back can we go
i think going that way
um in that situation i think
i think uh coach simmons probably would
have been comfortable from
he probably would have been comfortable
for like 57 but i think i probably would
have been comfortable from about 60. i
just kind of last played the game
um
kind of just go for it i think probably
around 60 yards because we were kind of
going into a win there just a just a
slight win
i'm looking at the numbers here i mean
these are these are impressive you've
had 11 field goals of 50 yards or more
most by any kicker in a single year all
time
you also are 18 for 18 on the road this
year
and i think your only miss was an extra
point on the road does that sound right
that's correct how the hell did you miss
the extra point
i i i couldn't tell you i mean i could
tell you technically what i did wrong i
kind of dropped the right shoulder left
my hips open and kind of push it out
right
but yeah that one hurt because it was in
the vegas game and you know i just came
off hitting
350 yard field goals and then a 48
or
a 350 yard field goals i had a 48 yarder
in that game too
um
and to miss that p-8 it really hurt me
and
from that point on i was like yeah this
is the worst feeling ever i i think
just going into it i just
i feel like people overthink pats a lot
and so just you know coming back and
just being like you know it's a pat come
on like you're not supposed to miss
those and
just kind of locking in on those again
so i that one hurt for sure you're from
alabama did alabama recruit you
they they kind of did uh as a punter and
it was funny because jk scott was on his
way out at the time and i had their
coach kind of weird dm'ing back and
forth and he's saying you know jk's
leaving this spot's going to open up is
this something you'd like to pursue and
at the time i was like
i knew i didn't want to punt in college
i knew i wanted to kick field goals and
so
they never really looked at me for for
to be a field goal kicker just kind of
as a punter so i'd say no
did you leave you left school early to
go pro right
i did
that that that normally doesn't happen
with factors
yeah for me uh the way i kind of thought
about it is you know i'm doing the same
thing here as i was in college and
some people might think it's actually
easier in the nfl just because the
hashes are moved in
but i guess the stage is brighter um
but i would say i mean i'm i'm doing
exactly what i was doing in college i'm
kind of just getting paid for it now and
i tell you what i'm having a lot more
fun right now than i really ever have so
why do they make it tougher on college
kickers with the hash marks i don't i
never understood that
i mean i i'm not really sure why they do
it um i don't know the uh
i guess
the stories behind the hashes and why
they're wider in high school and then
in college than the nfl i'm not honestly
i'm not really sure but
um
i can tell you honestly uh money mac
that's your nickname
i i tell people they can call me
whatever they want um
evan's fine if you want to call me evan
money mag shooter or whatever shooter um
you ever heard that one
no like well shooter mcgavin from
shooter mcgavin but so clark harris our
snapper actually came up with that one
um it was shooter mcpherson i think that
was after the kansas city game
and it was funny because i was in the
car with kevin or the punter after the
game
and he was telling me about the nickname
and i was like oh so it's like
um
kickoff for show field goals for dough
okay all right dry
putt for dough yeah i like that
i like kicker kickoff for show field
goals for
um mcfearless
that one's uh unique i i do like that
one um how about uh
kick fearson
kick fearsome
again i think it's along the same lines
as
uh
fearless or whatever you just but yeah i
like it all right i'm just i'm you know
we're workshopping this all right i got
it yeah i mean
i i kind of like kicked fearson
okay yeah i mean but i'd have to have
your approval to go with it i if you
want to stay with shooter we'll stay
with shooter
like i said
you can call me whatever you want to
call me
i'm fine with it okay whatever you like
the most you can just kind of roll with
it
are you checking the weather forecast in
kansas city
yeah so i mean that's we we looked at
that
um
probably before
um the tennessee game so we just had an
idea of you know what the weather was
going to be like either in buffalo or
kansas city if we were to win
um
and so i think it's supposed to be
around 35 35 to 40 degrees it's actually
supposed to be a pretty nice day um
winds are minimal i think
and that's kind of rare for kansas city
i know
well congrats so far
you know rookies aren't supposed to be
doing this and you're not old enough to
know all of the hardship that bengal
fans have had for decades in cincinnati
so you know joe comes in makes it look
easy jamar comes in makes it look easy
you too so congrats uh a lot of fun and
good luck in kansas city yeah thank you
so much and you know we're gonna go
we're gonna go out there and you know
give them our best shot and
hopefully take a nice trip to uh to
california after this week do you think
that there could be a moment where you
turn to somebody and you say looks like
we're going to the super bowl before you
go out and kick
if it comes down to a kick um or a
game-winning field goal yeah
i'll make sure to say it just to you
know challenge myself even more and you
know this is what i want for this
organization is to go to the super bowl
and you know hopefully win it and so if
it comes down to a field goal you know
just know i'm gonna they're gonna have
my best effort and uh you know i'm gonna
go out there with all intentions on
making it
congrats and uh good luck in kansas city
evan yep thank you that's uh evan
mcpherson the bengals kicker
shoots shooter shooter
i'm thinking shooter mcgavin
happy gilmore mcfearless evan kick
fearson